I want I want to start by thanking my
fellow candidates I want to thank the
returning officer I want to thank the
police and I want to thank the brilliant
staff of Doncaster Council for dealing
with all of the intricacies of today's
count I also want to thank above all
that people have Doncaster north for
reelecting me as their Member of
Parliament I want to thank my brilliant
Labour Party members who are here today
and I also want to take this opportunity
to thank all of the Labour Party members
right across our country who have done
such an extraordinary job throughout
this campaign
now the results are still coming in but
this has clearly been a very
disappointing and difficult night for
the Labour Party we haven't made the
gains we wanted in England and Wales and
then and in and in Scotland and in
Scotland we've seen a surge of
nationalism overwhelm a party now I want
to say to all the dedicated and decent
colleagues in Scotland who have lost
their seats that I'm deeply sorry for
what has happened and I also want to say
that the next government has a huge
responsibility it has a huge
responsibility in facing the very
difficult task of keeping our country
together whatever party we come from if
we believe in the United Kingdom we
should stand up for people in every part
of our United Kingdom
because you know I believe that what
unites us is much much more than what
divides us for it friends I'm now going
to go to London to await the full
results to come through but I just want
to reiterate my thanks to the people of
Doncaster North North it is a huge
privilege to be your Member of
Parliament is a huge privilege for you
to have placed your trust in me thank
you very much